it had been over two months since we
last heard anything about Counter-Strike
2. and honestly given valve's track
record I was getting a little bit
nervous but thankfully as of last night
they finally broke their Silence with a
substantial update that gave us tons to
chew on but given the fact that valve
has missed quite a few deadlines in the
past are we still getting CS2 this
summer
[Music]
alrighty folks before we get into the
video I wanted to remind you all that we
have a brand new show coming out this
weekend it's called into the dark and
we're making it in partnership with
Kraken rum it's a unique dive into the
incredible stories behind Gaming's
biggest protagonists as they took a leap
into the unknown and emerge Victorious
It's unlike anything we've ever done
before and you can check out the first
episode on June 10th so before we start
breaking down all this new information
we have I feel like it's necessary that
I mentioned that this video was
originally going to be about breaking
down IEM Dallas and what the hell is
actually going on with CS2 since we
haven't heard anything from valve but
about 25 minutes before I end my day
they dropped a new update so thank you
valve thank you so much all right so if
you're wondering why I'm making such a
big deal about this it's because the
whole CS2 Beta release tease has been
kind of a show the level of hype
when the first CS2 trailer dropped was
Indescribable but those feelings soured
fairly quickly the complaints fell into
two categories those who were sick and
tired of only only playing dust 2 and
the ridiculous queue times that came as
a result and those who were upset that
they didn't have access in the first
place to top it all off valve went radio
silent and I started to wonder if maybe
they kind of this up that this
entire time we weren't getting anything
new because they weren't actually ready
but by the grace of God or Gaben himself
we finally got some new information as
of last night starting things off say
goodbye to dust too that's right guys
the complaints have finally been
answered and the beta has now replaced
the most stale map in the game with the
second most tail map in the game Mirage
now you might be wondering why didn't
they just leave both Maps so this
doesn't happen again good
question it could be because they need
to make changes to dust too or they
really want to stress test Mirage your
guess is as good as mine all jokes aside
I am actually really hyped to see Mirage
in action it's arguably one of the most
competitively important maps in the game
all strats and executes were basically
birthed there and with no Sky boxes and
new smokes it'll be cool to see what
people can pull off but aside from that
we have to talk about the actual new
additions coming to CS2 because they are
huge may I introduce the brand new
Loadout system which revolutionizes the
weapons you bring into a match
Counterstrike obviously has more guns in
its Arsenal than you can bring into any
given map and when it came to specific
types of guns you would have to make a
choice do you want the CZ or the TEC-9
an MP5 or an MP7 and most notably CTS
could only use one of the m4s at a time
my friends those days are over with the
new Loadout menu you are able to bring
five weapons from three different
categories with you five pistols
including your obvious starting pistol 5
mid-tier weapons like SMGs and shotguns
and any five rifles this is very
important for a few reasons firstly
there are arguably a lot of useless
weapons in CS go and this honestly just
helps clean up your inventory secondly
you now don't have to make choices
between two weapons that you like to
carry for example I really like to use
the CZ in certain situations but the
tech 9 and 5 7 are objectively better
now I can take both the same goes for
the two m4s although they are very
similar they both excel in different
scenarios but for all of csgo's Lifetime
you were stuck to using one per match
now players will have that flexibility
find that you need more bullets so you
can anchor a site take the A4 this round
need to really tap heads and focus on
recoil control take the a1s it's
brilliant now to adjust for this change
valve also needed to rework the buy menu
say goodbye to the wheel and hello to
the flat Box menu thing regardless of
what you call it it's a net positive
change it's a lot cleaner more intuitive
and also lets you refund your purchase
if you miss click or change your mind
now a lot of people have been pointing
out that this new menu and refund
mechanic are very similar to valorence
and yeah that's the point Valerian has
done a lot of good in the name of
accessibility and valve would be silly
not to take any of it as inspiration and
honestly don't expect this to be the
last time either and given the fact that
Valerian took pretty much everything
else from Counter-Strike I think we can
call it even Boys Hey if I learned
stealing all of our bro we're
stealing the things that work
well for them take this one now next to
those two massive changes a bunch of
other small updates came in this new
patch there's a bunch of new Workshop
Tools that allows creators to start
working on Cosmetics for CS2 which is
dope backlive has now officially been
confirmed and matches will be stopped if
a cheater is detected much like
valerian's Vanguard system a bunch of
small animation and input tweaks have
also been implemented including changes
to the new smokes shotguns now make
bigger holes and the grenade trick
doesn't last as long anymore and finally
valve has made improvements to their
subtic system including fixing a bug
that prevented players at the top of a
triple Boost from shooting which I
didn't even know was a problem but I'm
glad to hear that regardless oh and last
but not least the Famas now has a new
sound and thanks to Mr Maxim for showing
it off since you know I don't have
access yet
now on the topic of access it's still a
big question mark valve has yet to say
anything about them adding more people
to the beta and I haven't heard anything
personally about a massive key drop so
the question is even with all these new
changes and a new map are we going to
see the same thing happen again people
play the out of it for two weeks
they get bored queue times hit the roof
and valve says nothing for months next
to that we still don't know if this game
is going to be ready for its summer
release for those that don't know there
is a term called valvetime which pokes
fun at the fact that valve usually
misses their projected release times and
when I say usually I mean from small
patches to basically every game valve
has ever released they are late
sometimes by years I am Dallas Banger
semi-final match between ends and phase
by the way go watch that if you have
time was thought to be the final big
tournament of csgo's life but we
actually have no idea if valve is going
to get this thing out on time for let's
say Cologne listen this is a nightmare
situation and I honestly don't think
it's going to happen but what if we we
live in a world where we get an
OverWatch 2 situation you know where the
pro circuit starts with the game before
we the general population can even play
it anyway I'm a cynic but what do you
guys think do you think valve is finally
for once going to hit a projected
release time is Counter-Strike 2 coming
out this summer and when it comes to all
these massive changes that were just
made what do you guys think do you love
them or do you hate them let me know in
the comments and as always stay safe and
have fun
on their website where they post like
their patch notes is like the most
unformatted patch they've ever done like
there's just like random spaces and at
the very end of it is a bracket with an
asterisk in the middle and I don't know
what that means could be nothing maybe
they're with us maybe it was an
accident what does the asterisk mean